- This is it.
This is the beans on the toast.
(funky guitar music)
- I've had beans, and I've had toast.
I've never had beans on toast.
- I've never heard of beans on toast.
I've usually heard that beans
are best served with barbecue.
- I'm a big fan of all the components, so
I expect it's going to be delicious.
- The beans just look like, ugh.
Like Spaghetti-Os gone wrong.
- You know, it smells almost like nothing.
- Golly, it looks like
a vegetarian sloppy joe.
- It smells so nasty.
- You know, this isn't bad.
- The bread is the exact same
consistency as the beans.
- Yeah, it tastes like the 4th of July.
Which for a British
food is pretty awkward.
- I don't know what I think.
- I'm sorry; I don't like it.
- It just tastes like totally edible,
flavorless beans on toast.
- I've eaten a lot of other weird things
and this is definitely not
the weirdest thing I've eaten.
I don't know why people are confused.
- Right, I mean, that's what I see.
I see a lot of lonely British men
going home to their flats and
preparing this for dinner,
wishing they had a wife.
- I think beans on toast
will catch on in America
because Americans love beans.
Everyone loves beans, and I don't get it.
- I mean, hey, we all have
our things that we eat
that are different, and you know what,
if it works for you, then why the hell not
put beans on toast.
- All right, okay, if I were
going to make beans on toast
it would be wholegrain bread, guacamole,
black beans, (mumbles).
And that's basically already at Chipotle.